this is the living tragedy more than 300
000 people in government shelters many
more sleep elsewhere that's for people
here
we lost our homes with us our neighbors
and it's it's very it's very difficult
it's very difficult people are helping
each other
this man collected milk from Farmers and
has come here to hand it out for free in
a bit we will be bringing cements and
pastries too we are doing this by
ourselves by our own will
so this is the long-term problem tens
and tens and tens of thousands of people
homeless across this region these people
are standing in line to get handouts
we get interrupted he says we don't have
any issues here everything is super
everything is great
we were intimidated and harassed by a
number of men in order to leave
determined to make sure there was no
negative coverage of the government it
seems
turkey's disaster management agency is
coordinating both local and
International Teams from this Center in
gaziantep it is a major task
the Turkish president arrived in the
city on Thursday as part of his visit to
the disaster zones
while the damage assessment is underway
in this transition moment we will
provide 530 dollars in financial aid to
our citizens and with this financial aid
we want at least to alleviate their
problems a little bit
foreign does anyone hear my voice he
shouts
they still haven't given up hope they
may find more survivors against all the
odds three people were pulled a line
from beneath the shattered building on
Thursday
some much needed good news in a region
of tragedy
Stephanie Decker Al Jazeera gaziantep